[Music]
this is star talk i'm your host neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist got with me my co-host
chuck knight chuck a baby hey neil all
right oh
always good to see you so today chuck
this is an overdue topic for star talk i
don't know why we didn't do this years
ago we're going to talk about
horror
in particular
horror movies horror stories and why
people like it that's just weird it is
weird it's like why
why why do you like being scared out of
your gourd why why
what is this and and believe it or not
there is a person who studies this
professionally
okay as as you know we reach into the
academic halls to find people with just
the kind of expertise necessary for that
topic and today we have
mathias kleisen i think i pronounced his
name right and he's director of the
get this
recreational
fear lab okay at arms university now
that let me just tell you
you ain't gonna find no brother anywhere
who wants to engage in recreational fear
our lives are filled with too much real
fear actual for us to be like you know
what i think i'm going to do is relax
with a little bit of fear
[Laughter]
excuse me could you do me a favor could
you put some red and blue lights on
while i'm driving
[Laughter]
i just want to experience a bit of
recreational fear right wait and there's
that spooky house on the hill let's go
hide in it yeah that's right
so the art house university is in
denmark yeah so he's danish here and
he's associate editor checking his his
pedigree here associate editor
evolutionary studies and imaginative
culture
i mean this is this is this is like my
gosh
people have expertise in this stuff
author of why
horror
seduces
and and something that's it's coming out
around now is a very nervous person's
guide to horror movies
and so this and it got a ted talk
lessons from a terrified horror
researcher
so this is
all right we got it here this is
mattias has all the bases covered man
but mathenius tell me first welcome to
star talk welcome thank you thank you
okay excellent i don't know what
recreational fear is i'm sorry you're
gonna have to explain that one
right yeah i think it's a concept that
we invented for the occasion
we defined it as those kinds of
activities in which people derive
pleasure from fear
so the prototypical crazy crazy people
do that yeah yeah okay actually
well we can get back to that
but know the the prototypical example of
recreational fear is probably horror
horror movies uh stephen king novels or
video games haunted attractions
but also activities like extreme sports
or um pretending you're a monster and
chasing your kids through the apartment
that's a kind of recreational fear
um activity in which the child gets to
experience what it feels like to be a
little bit afraid while realizing there
is no real danger so it's fear while
maintaining the cocoon of safety you
feel you know that you're safe but yet
somehow you're tricking your brain into
feeling like you're scared right
okay wow
okay
so so and you would distinguish that
from like act like chuck is saying
actual fear where there is no safety net
there or you don't know that there's a
safety net so the fear
triggers different things within you
yeah so did you did you come to this uh
as someone who's just a big fan of uh
horror novels what's your background on
this
yeah well i used to not be a big fan i
used to get nightmares from the most you
know innocent ghost story but then
something changed in my teenage years
and that's a very usual trajectory
a kind of hedonic reversal where what
used to be a versus
aversive to me became uh attractive
aren't teens a big part of the
marketplace for horror movies yeah they
are
we did some studies on that the
relationship between age and horror
liking um but but so yeah my
professional interest really grows out
of you know personal fascination
is that and so that is the normal
trajectory what you yours or no yours is
the reverse
well the normal trajectory is that kids
are fascinated with scary stuff but
mildly scary stuff and then that
fascination kind of increases
uh during development and it peaks in
the late teenage years and then it
slowly decreases for the rest of one's
life
gotcha
yeah so i'm fairly unfairly difficult in
that respect okay well that may explain
why i live my entire life terrified
because
[Laughter]
i can't grow up
but why is it that okay if that's an arc
and if it's normal and it's and it's a
common human trait
why isn't it in everyone like what what
do we have our numbers here is about
only about half of people like horror i
would be in like the other half right
it's not that i i'm afraid of it or
don't i'm just not interested all right
and so uh once again the scientists look
at that
once again the analytical mind it's
mostly
overrides everything yeah it kind of did
it kind of did and so
so tell me what
what's going on why
what is the recipe in the half of people
that do enjoy this versus those that
don't am i missing something or do i
have something that my half doesn't have
yeah i wish i wish i knew i mean we've
been trying to get a grip on the
personality profile of horror fans i
teamed up with
a good colleague and skill christian
he's a he's a media scholar
and so we tried to get a fix on what um
big five personality traits are
correlated with horror liking
and
thrill seeking seems to be a personality
trait that
is related to enjoying horror movies but
also a trait called openness to
experience so people who enjoy new
adventures intellectual stimulation
uh but you would fit that bill uh so i'm
not sure what exactly well in my mind
but not my body okay
it's like so say once you put your body
in this vice that's a new experience no
i can think that one through
yes
right so there's a difference between uh
what your body's going through and what
your mind goes through i guess
see and it's funny though i am not a fan
of horror films simply because i don't
the scary part is really too scary for
me and and i'm and i've you know i know
you and you're black just saying well
let's say for real
okay let's say let's exactly because you
know and i am that person who's in the
theater going no girl don't go in there
don't come in oh my god don't just do
yourself did you just hear that am i the
only one who heard that like okay
don't hide next to the chainsaw right
exactly he's right behind you right so
i mean
i have to be honest though i am fully
aware on an intellectual level that you
know that i'm in no danger and that uh i
have suspended disbelief so that i can
be a part of this experience
but yet
what's what happens to me afterwards
i can't take
i can't take it it keeps replaying in my
head and it starts to affect me and that
that's just what happens to me you know
but i am but yet i'm a thrill seeker
right so mattias tell us about the
what's going on inside someone
physiologically while they're
experiencing it versus what effect it
might have on them later and not only
just intellectually but how about
biophysiologically what do you know
about changes in the body and in the
mind right so we know that when people
experience recreational fear horror
specifically
they get the physiological arousal that
is associated with
fear so they experience fear but they
find pleasure in that experience so it's
not just
i mean they experience fear and joy at
the same time and there is a peculiar
relationship between fear and enjoyment
in these kinds of recreational
activities and that is something we have
actually measured in a study we did in a
haunted attraction
where we looked at the relationship
between fear and enjoyment and we found
that there is a sweet spot
uh it used to be the case that people
thought that the more fear the more
enjoyment i mean you've seen
movie trailers for
horror films that say you know you won't
sleep for two weeks where this will
scare the crap out of you
uh kind of suggesting that the scarier
the better but it turns out actually if
we look at the heart
rate and people's self-reported
experience there is a sweet spot just so
just right amount of fear that is
conducive to the most pleasure
so so lots of physiological arousal the
heart is hammering the palms get sweaty
the mind is kind of narrowed on the
stimulus the movie or the actors who are
trying to scare you
and then afterwards um it takes a while
for people to calm down and most people
actually claim that they have
some lingering effects that they feel
more vigilant that they you know they
watch a horror movie they go into the
basement to collect the laundry and they
think that tiny little sound in the
corner
evidence of a chainsaw killer
going into the basement for any reason
anything
yeah nothing good ever happened in a
basement all right people get buried
there
okay yeah so
and what about uh your immune system
what would be what were we reading about
this
um there is some evidence to suggest
that there is a short-term boost to the
immune system from watching a horror
movie
uh but this is it's very preliminary the
doctor is not going to recommend horror
movies
anytime soon
so what you're saying is it it could
give you a heart attack but if it didn't
kill you but if it doesn't you have a
better immune system
well it's super rare that people die
from from fright and watching horror
movies super rare
wow take two freddy kruegers and call me
in the morning there you go
so is this some of what you talked about
in your ted talk just the sort of the
physiological uh responses here right so
how about your people's mental health
right does it improve it
is it different yeah yeah that's you
know that's one of the most exciting uh
lines of research that we're pursuing um
because people used to think that it was
probably bad for your mental health i
mean there's a lot of
bias and prejudice associated with
horror that is psychologically harmful
that it's morally corrosive
it could turn you into the person
committing the horror yeah exactly i
mean puppy cats or whatever yeah i got
to tell you that's the reason why i
worship the devil
same here right
oh well so so it does look actually like
there can be
positive health effects we did a study
during the pandemic where we looked at
psychological resilience
and uh horror movie consumption and it
looks like people who watch a lot of
horror movies actually had better mental
health during the pandemic possibly
because they have a lot of practice in
fear regulation so they watch horror
movies they get scared and they use a
bunch of strategies to regulate their
own fear and then they use those
strategies also in you know real life
gotcha so you watch a lot of zombie
movies yeah all of a sudden this
pandemic comes and you're like it's a
walk in the park yeah you're like i'm
good
i've already been through like eight
zombie apocalypses
this is nothing because uh a
a pandemic such as that
approximates some of the early stages of
a zombie apocalypse that's right because
in a zombie apocalypse certain
industries get taken out because all
those workers are dead or zombified so
they're not making the toilet paper
right they're not producing the energy
they're not producing you see these
shortages in society so wow so the
horror movie folks were just chilling
exactly they were um and that's um
that's why the cdc had a zombie
apocalypse campaign 10 years ago
they said that if you're ready for the
zombie apocalypse you're ready for any
kind of disaster
wow oh wow
[Laughter]
that's amazing wait i'm just reminded
there's a skit on somebody's sketch
comedy where there's this neighborhood
right it's an integrated neighborhood
and so there's some black folks over on
the side with the barbecue and other
white folks and zombies are coming down
the street
and they turn towards the
black home and then they
turn away and keep walking
and they only
eat the white people as i said these are
racist zombies
that's a funny sketch actually it was a
pretty it was a pretty crazy sketch um
but we don't like dark meat that's funny
look for it it's somewhere online you
gotta find it racist zombies but but
mathias
tell me if i have a prior condition
could it
be worsened so sorry not necessarily a
prior physiological condition but a
prior mental condition
if i if i come from war and i have some
ptsd
is could this trigger something within
me that's that's a big that's an
important word these days what triggers
you yeah
i think it could go either way um so
there is some
evidence to suggest that people with
pre-existing mental health conditions
can be hurt by horror movies
but there is also now emerging some
evidence to suggest that people with
anxiety disorders actually get relief
from watching horror movies so that they
they self-medicate with scary movies
for a bunch of reasons i think partly
because if you have an anxiety disorder
you find yourself in this fog of
free-floating anxiety day in and day out
with no clear source and no
control but no benchmarking of it yeah
no no calibration for it yeah exactly
and that kind of calibration and the
sense of control and a clear
identifiable source comes with seeking
out a horror movie and maybe also
the kind of practicing of coping skills
the emotion regulation
expertise that you can develop through
engagement with recreational fear
well we got to take a quick break but
when we come back
more on the sort of physiology and
psychology of fear with matthias clayton
i think again did i pronounce your name
right sir
closely mathias mathias clayson yes
there it goes on star talk
we're back start off part two of our
investigation into horror
what it feels like
what
what you're thinking how you react to
horror movies and horror stories and
we've got one of the world's experts on
this matthias clayson and he's the
director of the recreational fear lab
yes such a thing exists at the aarhus
university uh and this is in denmark of
course
so let's let's let's continue with this
um mathias tell me about um
do you have to keep feeding the horror
to the person
or it's just one or few of these
experience good enough for them to just
reflect on it so in other words is it
like a drug do you have to get more and
more and more of it as you continue
in order to derive pleasure from it yeah
yeah exactly okay do
does your thresholding keep rising and
you have to then get more and more of it
i think i think probably yes i think
i think there is a kind of habituation
um just as same as if you're you know
an aficionado of hot peppers you know
you'll probably graduate to ever
increasing you build a tolerance yeah
yeah
and i think you build tolerance in
different ways i mean once you've seen
something
that shocked you if you see it many
times then it kind of loses its ability
to shock you and also over time people
develop media literacy
they become better at
using strategies for
reducing fear in response to a horror
movie for example by reminding
themselves that it's just a movie or by
seeing through the effects that create
the scares
interesting it's funny because you know
the same thing happens kind of with
comedians they don't
they don't laugh they and then what they
do laugh at
becomes more and more dark
they just they become more and more they
become exceedingly dark uh
and the darker it is the more it elicits
a laugh which is how many of them just
end up getting canceled yeah okay yeah
that's where they drive off the cliff
right when that happens right right they
don't see the warning signs
of it so
so you still haven't told me mathias
why some people love it and some people
hate it or some people are indifferent
i'm more in the in different camp mm-hmm
why
if it's that physiologically
um potent
why isn't it 100
reaction right i was sort of hoping you
wouldn't get back to that because
i don't know
oh you know that's fine
that's fine because what we will be
doing in our third segment is bringing
on
our favorite neuroscientist to tell us
what research in neuroscience says about
this because you come to this at from
the literary side of
academia correct yes but you're still
doing experiments on people so that's
cool yeah sort of like experimental
psychology yes
i teamed up with people who you know who
have expertise in cognitive psychology
and experimental studies so uh it's a
big part of what we do
wow
and and so
is chuck right that if you spend a lot
of your life
um
in danger
in actual danger
that
you're not gonna want to
go into situations where there's pretend
danger because it doesn't really do
anything for you
another example you cause you you
correlated horror movie watching with
what did you say um extreme sports or
extreme
uh experiences you know jumping out of
airplanes and things and
uh to chuck's point
i i don't know how many
black people have ever died
purposefully jumping out of an airplane
because they just don't do that okay
that just thinks no i'm just going to
try to survive this walk down the street
all right rather than jumping out of
planes so is there any truth to
the dangers you experience in everyday
life and whether you want to seek them
out in these forms of entertainment
right that's one of the many many things
we don't know um i'm not so sure
um because uh
horror movies did better than ever
before in 2020 and 2021 i mean the
market share of horror movies just blew
up
so people are finding themselves in a
pretty scary world
and yet they seek to scary entertainment
perhaps as a context in which they can
confront
you know anxiety and and have a little
bit of fun with it derive a little bit
of pleasure from it
yeah but if you can get accustomed to
what's the term you used you uh
the novelty of the horror can wear off
and they have to sort of do it a little
differently next time i'm reminded when
steven spielberg spoke of jaws he had a
regret
in that movie the regret was he showed
twice
a bobbing decapitated head in the water
right okay and he said i should have
never done that a second time because he
he watched people's reaction the first
time he was like
the second time oh another bobbing head
and it completely lost the impact and so
that was one of his earliest movies and
he learned from that right and so
um
the
i'm just curious
if you
if showing the same thing twice loses
its novelty
haven't we run out of horror movie plots
by now
ways to scare people are we done
no i mean we've been going over the same
basic plot structure for probably
thousands of years
you know good guys medieval monsters and
may or may not survive
so it's kind of like the blues you have
a few chords and you can get a lot of
creativity out of different combinations
of those chords so i think that the
building blocks of horror are few and
basic and they are circumscribed by
human biology the kinds of things we
fear um are reflected in horror i get
what you're saying but why is it that
the things that we fear are never like
the real things we fear
are very rarely represented in horror
films like for me the horror film would
be
the mortgage is late again
like that that would be like the horror
film that i would have to go with what
that's like a real fear
you know um and you know they're they
always tend to be supernatural
um and if they're not especially stephen
king stories yeah yeah yeah if they're
not supernatural then the supernatural
element is just not acknowledged but
it's there and then if it deviates not
deviates but if it's not that then it's
kind of like slasher like even like
freddy krueger which is supernatural
right he's still just really it's a
slasher film yeah
i think i think the the stuff that does
occur over and over again in horror you
know the the the haunting the demons the
ghosts the zombies the
all the creepy supernatural stuff and
those crazy killers and hockey masks and
wearing chainsaws i mean that stuff is
dramatic that stuff is potent and it
sparks the imagination now if you if you
wanted to sell a movie you know a
shocking thriller about the overdue
mortgage nobody's gonna buy it because
you know
[Music]
it doesn't really
it doesn't evoke it
it'd be true but it wouldn't be an
economic success right exactly chuck
knight stars
so matthias tell me
why tell me about the startle reflex
some people have it for better or for
worse and others don't
and is it because
they're expecting to be scared and then
it happens in a way they don't expect it
or what's going on inside the mind for
that yeah yeah so so the jump scare is
one of the most
common well-known and universally
detested um tropes of horror movies we
all know the jumpscare you know the
character is going around dark basement
somewhere they shouldn't be and then
suddenly boom
something nasty jumps out and you hear a
loud sudden noise and everybody in the
movie theater jumps
so the so the jump scare and there are
about 10 jump scares per uh horror movie
it's designed to really um
engage the startled response which is a
very basic biological reflex basically
we share it with
a bunch of other animals i mean you can
you can do a jump scare on a cat if you
have a cat
or uh or a fainting goat
exactly yes
and they respond in a fairly similar way
right so the jumpscare is a really
effective technique and lots of people
frown on it because it seems cheap you
know it's easy to create a jump scare
you can do it not only visually but all
also um with sound yes you can have it
quite and then there's a loud sound even
if nothing jumps in the way that can
startle you too right
so let me ask you this so i got a 15
year old son and he loves horror films
and so do all of his kids i mean his
friends right
here's the thing
they kind of have this um
they've all adopted this disposition
where the less scared you are the more
analytical you are
then the better you are at watching
horror films so
if there's a jump scare he's like oh
that's bs ah that's you know i can't
believe you fell for the jump scare and
they're like so is is that some kind of
just like i don't know are you a poser
if you're scared of jump scares because
they scare the hell out of me right uh
they scare the hell out of me as well um
and but it sounds like your kid and his
friends are using a very effective
coping strategy i mean you know
approaching horror movies as
construction they're trying to get
behind the scenes and see the jump scare
for what it is
a cinematic technique
and that's one of the reasons why i
think people should watch horror movies
with their kids to teach them how to
approach it analytically
because that's an important skill
um so except that he's the one teaching
me
yes yeah the roles are flipped around
reverse yeah um do you have any insights
into
how or why uh key and peel after that
racist zombie skit that they
performed
chuck that hadn't seen it until the
break he didn't tell the break and i got
to tell you man
looking at it during the break oh my god
it's hilarious yeah yeah so
and what happens so uh jordan peele
afterwards
does a horror movie called get out no
right and so is there
is this something every director wants
to do do you think
you got to have at least one of these in
your portfolio or any thoughts about
that
yeah that's
a really interesting question because uh
horror movies
for the longest time have been
associated with
low brow
mindless low budget um aesthetically
uninteresting fluff basically i mean i
work in an english department and
i'm a horror researcher and you know
it's not it doesn't have the same
cultural
prestige as being an expert in
renaissance poetry or
you know the sonnets of shakespeare
so lots of do you think
i think i do think that
but
i can imagine just going down the
faculty resumes right
it's like my expert on renaissance and
on shakespeare on a milton
horror movies right okay yeah but we
love you that's why we have you on the
show we don't have any of your
colleagues here that's okay
right
screw those pompous asses
for sure um but um
but i think some of that uh some of that
um prejudice uh toward hora is actually
going away and i think one large reason
is the success of get out because
uh peel very consciously used
uh storytelling devices from the horror
genre and from science fiction to tell a
story that was very um
progressive he wanted to change things
in the world and he did that by using
the tools of horror yeah and it was
socially relevant the way yeah of course
the whole everything everything about it
so let me ask you this speaking of what
you guys just brought up which is uh
jordan peele and horror
is there any combination where comedy
actually enhances the effects of horror
or
vice versa where being scared makes you
you know enjoy the laughter anymore i
don't know of any real uh like comedy
horror films but even a scary movie is a
comedy horror film what are you talking
about but it didn't scare me
oh okay yeah made fun of the genre it
made fun of it it was a parody whereas
get out scared me and there were some
really funny moments in that movie yeah
that's true that's true good point yeah
i think for one thing the the the kind
of the contrast between laughter and and
screams can be used very effectively in
a movie like get out or you know cabin
in the woods or
i'm reading joe hill right now one of my
favorite writers and he is hilarious but
you can also write some really scary
stuff
but also i think often the line between
humor and horror is kind of it's a it's
a thin and porous line
something can be so horrible on the
screen that it kind of becomes grotesque
and funny like in the evil dead movies
uh it's just over the top and you know
you it's it's
it's so far out that you stop screaming
and you start laughing so it's a kind of
thin line
could it be like there's a scene in
jurassic park where t-rex
uh bites into the outhouse
and
grabs the the lawyer who's on the toilet
and
swallows him in one gulp that's kind of
funny
made me laugh just made me laugh just
hear you bring it up again
i pictured it in my head and i started
giggling because it's
i mean nobody wants to be on a toilet
and then eaten by by by t-rex but no
this was a kind of a reprehensible
character exactly
he was a lawyer yeah
wow okay
actually you know on the topic of you
mentioned jaws before and they had this
mechanical shark made for the movie
which kept you know
uh get got broken
so that's that's one of the reasons why
you only see the shark for like a couple
of minutes during the two-hour movie but
they actually took to calling it bruce
after uh spielberg's lawyer so this show
was named after
nice
well matthias we're gonna have to say
goodbye to you uh for a third segment
we're gonna bring in a a neuroscientist
to sort of see what they have to say
about this very same genre but i don't
know what they'll know that you don't
know because you've been doing all these
experiments and that's ultimately how we
get the answers in science
but it's been a delight to talk to you
it's been a like to even know that you
exist
as a person with this expertise because
as an academic i just love it that
somebody just devoted their lives to
something that everyone else either just
takes for granted or doesn't think
there's anything there because there
usually is when you part the curtains
you know what we never got to
your favorite horror film of all time
oh oh let's ask that sure before just
before we go what is that um let's say
uh oh it's hard um halloween by uh john
carpenter
wow
very classic classic yeah i haven't seen
nearly as many harsh films as you i've
probably seen one percent of them that
you have but i have to put up there the
omen right oh yeah also just because the
idea of what was going on yeah to me it
wasn't how bloody things were or
anything it was just oh my gosh
this is actually happening this is
terrifying
and
and it was because it's like a huge
conspiracy
playing out the entire movie right and
there's nothing you can do to stop that
conspiracy from unfolding correct
correct correct
so that was spooky that's a good one how
about you chuck oh man uh
i'm gonna say finding nemo
okay
that shark scared the wits out of here
yeah bruce bruce got me first got me man
[Laughter]
all right no we got a holy quits there
so
so matthias do you have a website we can
direct people to or social media well my
lab has a website it's
fear.au.dk and i'm also on twitter and
to try to share some of our exciting
findings so and what's your handle on
twitter uh it's my name uh so the funny
looking a and then matthias clayson
got it
matthias clayson okay yeah yeah all
right dude well thanks for being on star
talk when we come back we're going to
bring in heather berlin
she's our our neuroscientist at large
and she's going to tell us all about
what's happening in the neurochemistry
of fear and startling and
anything else
that might keep you awake at night we'll
be right back
we're back star talk we're talking about
the science of fear of recreational fear
coming off of two segments with one of
the world's experts in that subject
there is that subject of course uh from
the recreational fear lab matthias
clayson
in is it denmark chuck where that was i
think so yes it is denmark yeah yeah
yeah so we thought we'd bring in our
favorite neuroscientist to see what she
has to say about
heather berlin heather welcome back hey
always good to have you in arms reach of
us um because we we get to these moments
where i don't know what's going on you
know what's going on chuck
so neuroscientist clinical psychologist
associate clinical professor of
psychiatry and neuroscience at the icon
school of medicine mount sinai
not the i can't school
heather what's your favorite scary movie
favorite uh i like psychological
thriller so i'm into like silence of the
lambs and that kind of genre okay you
know i don't know if i have a favorite i
mean poultry guys really left a mark on
me as a kid
that really you know there are some that
are just imprinted in my brain and
that's one of them yeah so tell me about
people who seek this stuff out
because what came up in a previous
segment was chuck and i were
commiserating we're saying
you know
[Laughter]
just just if if if your life is already
a risk
just walking down the street because you
grew up in a tough neighborhood or the
cops might be beating up on you you're
not saying gee i want more scary horror
in my life
so we were hypothesizing
that if you live a life
of danger and risk that you don't then
need to seek it out so can you
distinguish between those two
i do think that there is some truth to
that um you know some of the joy uh or
the pleasure that people get out of
sensation seeking or seeing horror films
and getting themselves scared
um does that include jumping out of
airplanes i mean that kind of thing as
well
yeah yeah it does it does it
you know
it's the same physiologic reaction where
you're getting that sort of fight or
flight response you're getting the
cortisol the adrenaline
and depending on the context you're in
you could interpret it as being a really
pleasurable sensation or a really
terrifying sensation but the actual
physiologic response is the same it's
just how you perceive it how you
interpret it which is context dependence
changes so so some people who maybe are
slightly under stimulated as a baseline
chronically are seeking out those higher
levels of stimulation to feel satisfied
to feel good and there's also something
about scaring yourself in a scenario
where you know there's no real threat
um because then you get that sort of
high and then there's also that release
when you're what's called the
parasympathetic nervous system kicks in
and calms everything down that's also
very pleasurable
so so that's pleasurable because you
were in a tense state and then you come
out of the tent state and that
transition is where you derive the
pleasure i guess is that right exactly
exactly the release of tension as well
is really pleasurable yeah you know
it's kind of weird it's kind of like uh
hitting my thumb with a hammer and then
sticking it in some ice
you know it's like
damn that hurt oh that feels so good
right
well this is how chuck brings pleasure
to his life only after he imparts pain
yes okay
well there are some people who have who
are dealing with different you know
psychological issues that are in a lot
of psychological pain and they they
self-harm you know
people who cut themselves harm
themselves um because in a way it is a
release of tension of psychological
tension that they have but but but
there's something about it also brings
you into the moment there's an immediacy
so if you think of um a free climb or a
rock climber you know they can't think
about all their problems or anticipate
things about the future you're right
there in the moment there's an intensity
to it that's also um there's something
pleasurable about it but people who
in their everyday life are living under
constant stress um or who have to be
sort of hyper vigilant uh they tend to
not be as attracted to
uh scaring themselves for entertainment
purposes uh so you know and people who
have come out of let's say war
situations or have sort of ptsd and are
hyper vigilant so any little thing can
trigger them they're not looking for
more stimulation they're already sort of
chronically overstimulated and don't
need any more it's people who kind of
maybe need a bit more to get that same
high so i would i would intuit that you
got that if you grew up in a in a sort
of uh environment that was threatening
you're not going to be attracted to
these horror films but is there any
therapeutic value to
purposefully scaring someone if for
example they had ptsd or some other kind
of um
some other kind of trauma in their life
does more trauma but controlled help get
them out of it or do you just avoid it
all together
yeah and that's part of what exposure
therapy is about the idea that that's
the term i was looking for there yeah
yeah exposure therapy so you you
basically you create a hierarchy with
somebody so like what is like your worst
fear you'd rate it like a 10 all the way
down to a one and what you do is you you
start out with something that where
they're at like a a five or a six in
terms of their fear and anxiety you
expose them to a situation but it's
still a safe environment until they
eventually habituate so the brain over
time can't be chronically
in the state of fear eventually it
subsides and then when the person gets
down to say a a one or a two in terms of
their fear level then you take them up
to the next notch and so you keep sort
of gra it's called gradual exposure um
gradually exposing a person to their
worst fears until their brain learns
okay you don't have to be afraid of this
anymore these are when people are having
irrational fears right if it was
something a real fear you know you're
not going to expose them to right so
of course of course so it's like good
tolerance instead of bad tolerance like
alcohol is bad tolerance
you got to keep drinking more and more
and then this you actually want to ramp
it up so that you can come down no but
for example if you fear pigeons that's
not rational right because the pigeon is
not in there or even spiders you know
it's the picture sitting
over top of me
that might
no you fear pigeon poop that's different
that's a difference
that's true
yeah um so let's say you fear a spider
for example you know
you know it's also interesting is that
there are some evolutionary
predispositions we have to certain types
of fears so people aren't born
necessarily with the fear of electric
sockets right because that wasn't you
know that didn't exist the serengeti
didn't have electric sockets no
so they only had one prong sockets the
two prong and three prong came later
so we don't we don't have so that's not
a common fear what are common fears
claustrophobia heights you know fear of
of insects or spiders um because i think
there is a genetic component to certain
types of fears that that we are
predisposed to um then there's also
learned fears over time if you see
somebody in your environment growing up
that's always afraid of say a spider you
might learn that fear as well but with
the exposure is that you first you you
see what they can tolerate maybe it's
just the picture of a cartoon of a
spider and then you get them to
habituate that and then you show them a
real spider then over time with this
process you can get someone who is
terrified of spiders to hold the
tarantula in their hand and be okay with
it so i wonder if chuck this applies to
comedy like you start people out slow
and then you can get them to laugh at
you
no it doesn't work that way
you start out slow and then it's all
downhill
so heather what about people who
who don't have a fear factor but still
love horror movies like what are they
getting out of it
people who love what this is the thing
with horror films is that it activates
this sort of fear center of your brain
the amygdala um and and there's a way in
a sense it's like you're almost
rehearsing for if there was a real
threat but you're doing it in a safe
environment
so you're kind of um okay well what
would what would happen if i was walking
down the street alone and i heard a
strange noise or a man came at me and
then you're in a way you're you're
putting yourself in the scenario
um
playing it out and then you'll have a
toolkit for if anything like that ever
happened to you in real life so there is
some sort of rehearsal aspect to it as
well yeah the problem with that
rehearsal is in all these movies the
people do the dumbest thing ever
you know it's just like yeah well let's
run to the shed
yeah
no
no you know that's where all the tools
are okay
okay so chuck that's a different
question for heather heather why are the
teens in horror movies so stupid yeah
their prefrontal cortex is not fully oh
that's right you got it
you got a man oh my gosh there's no
rational thought it's just pure
adrenaline and no rationality
it would not be believable if you had a
40 year old person saying let's run to
the haunted house to be safe from the
scary things that doesn't play
accurately very good no no because we
have a more evolved prefrontal cortex we
can kind of override the fear response
think things through a little bit more
and make more logical decisions and and
also sex isn't worth dying for because
we've had it like you know because they
always die you know what i mean so it's
just like it's like
meet me by the lake and we'll go skinny
dipping and it's like nah
nah how about this you meet me at two
o'clock tomorrow afternoon okay
and we will do it how about that
i don't have to go to the lake at
midnight to have sex
so so heather what about the startle
response i mean you could be like
intellectually afraid but to be startled
for example i bet when you were watching
silence of the lambs there's nothing
really startling in that right
so what's the difference between
not being startled but still being
afraid oh yeah
so okay well the startle response is is
almost it's an unconscious response
right you know the brain it's there's
there's different pathways in the brain
there's one that just goes straight to
the amygdala that sets off this um
sympathetic nervous system which which
puts into place this fight or flight
response and that can happen
automatically that's kind of a startle
response so stimulus comes in a loud
noise you jump um then there's the kind
of slower more cognitive fear response
which is that psychological thriller
that is more about the anticipation
which is building up a suspense and the
fear of what might happen and films are
really good at doing that you know
that's how i felt with get out by the
way that wasn't specifically a horror
movie but it had me terrified just
because i
as i said in the earlier segments i i i
have been in situations
that greatly resembled many of the
scenes portrayed in that film
and
you know people come here i like your
body i like this i like that it's like
okay why what do you you know what what
yeah and they took this to like a scary
extreme where people then start bidding
on your body after a brain transplant
and so they don't want your brain they
want your body it's like whoa
so i mean that's and it has more to do
with anxiety so the difference between
anxiety and fear is you know anxiety
is
anticipation of a future threat
something bad might happen and so you're
getting these cues and these signals
like
you need to be prepared something bad
might potentially happen though it
hasn't happened yet
and that's that's anxiety fear is that
immediate it's happening right now run
for your life
um and so there's this subtle difference
between the two and humans are um one of
the only animals that actually can have
anxiety which is fear of a future
um potentially bad something happening
because we can think far into the future
animals are more just having an
immediate fear response and less so
about anticipation of a future um
no animal ever said next week this could
be bad for me
that's not a thing exactly
wait wait so so heather if there's
can you explain to me the difference
between
fear factors on things that we obviously
didn't evolve to be afraid of so
so some people might be afraid of a
chainsaw
some people might be afraid of
some other weaponry
or
and people tend to be more afraid of
that than just a gun
right since when are guns ever used in
horror movies like never
that's that's too boring right but it's
but it's probably a more potent means of
you losing your life
so
the most unlikely way of dying doesn't
scare you but the thing that could be
outlandish
terrifies you yes i i so guns should be
scary yes and but they're not used in
horror movies it's the hatchet the
chainsaw the
you know something else yeah oh well
maybe it's because we're in america and
everybody knows that there's a really
good chance you gonna get shot
so now a hatchet is like oh my god
that's
that's terrifying like nobody gets
hatcheted right so so
so is it because they're they're getting
more and more inventive with ways they
can kill you in a horror movie
so
what i think first of all with guns um
part of it is we've habituated to guns
um they're not as scary because they're
we see them so often um
and it's also tends to be a very quick
death right you get shot you die
these other forms of death that they
tend to use in horror films kind of drag
it out they're more um gruesome
in a way you know um but outside of that
even you know there are there are
psychological aspects to this
particularly classical conditioning so
the original studies of classical
conditioning with somebody it was little
albert um it was called them they
basically it was a little boy and they
played this really loud startling noise
for him and then they paired that
startling noise which was the thing that
was just before that was outlawed
yeah these were experiments like in the
1950s before we
had the ethical okay
you said it like yeah i got albert next
door you know
by the way he became my husband
later on little little albert became
jason
this poor kid and so they trained him to
fear this loud noise then what they did
is they would hear the loud noise um
with like a little i think it was like a
white rabbit or something or a little
white rat and then it became fear of the
white rat and then that generalized
to fear of any white fluffy thing and
over time you start to make these sort
of associations and so that's sort of
part of what we're they're playing at in
some horror films like maybe it's not
even the knife you're afraid of but it's
you know
walking into the the store that sells
you know knives or whatever it is it
starts to
you can generalize out so the fear
expands to all these other objects that
are surrounding the actual fearful thing
so so the best horror making horror
movie producers are those who've spoken
to you in advance and no
[Laughter]
i don't
films yeah i mean well filmmakers really
do understand the psychology of fear and
they really play on your fear part of it
has to do with uncertainty so there's a
suspense there's a build up there
they're playing with your because when
you're uncertain if something is going
to be there is there going to be a tiger
present or not you're you're hyper
vigilant you're paying um exquisite
attention to what's happening in the
environment anticipating something
happening so they they kind of wrap you
rope you in with that with some
suspension music
and then it's the shock you know the
fear and that's where the adrenaline
surges so they're playing with your
neural chemicals in ways that they they
understand how after working with people
like me um and and they they're
masterful at it um so it's like almost
like when you enter a movie theater
you're allowing your brain to be played
in a way and you're going on a kind of
emotional rollercoaster ride and you're
allowing yourself to go on that with
them um but that the music the lights
this the light all of it is to build the
suspense and the unexpected and then
suddenly
you know burst out and scare you what
about being scared of things that are
not real and we're never real you know
like ghosts or vampires yeah vampires
like why is it because we have such a
good imagination that they never real
become real for us to fear them that
just it's it feels very
um inefficient evolutionarily
inefficient to fear things that never
existed yeah like my uh irrational fear
of santa claus
so
we have these evolutionarily older
systems that are at play and they can be
easily triggered by by uncertainty
ghosts it's sort of it's this
uncertainty you hear a sound you hear a
noise and then of course we've been fed
information from films from the time
we're little kids right so this imagery
has gotten in there and we make these
associations even though our rational
brain our prefrontal cortex knows you
know there's no such thing as the
boogeyman for example
but
there's this more animalistic part of
our brain that's been fed this
information over many years and so it
can't help but sort of have an automatic
thought like oh what if it's a ghost
what if it's the boogie man and then
only after does your prefrontal cortex
kick in and give you sort of is is
giving you a rationalization
um of the fear and then it can start to
quell it then it starts to down regulate
the amygdala the fear center of the
brain so what happens is first the
amygdala the fear is triggered
crazy thoughts can you know pop up based
on things that you were exposed to in
childhood even and then the prefrontal
cortex says oh no no it's okay you know
it was just the cat knocking something
over and then it calms down the amygdala
i guess and then you need all the pieces
and working together in a sequence
they're really interesting yeah because
when i was like i was a very geeky kid
and i just rationalized away almost all
fear that would grip others in intention
what are you afraid of are you afraid of
anything yeah see
almost yeah i can't think of anything i
i don't startle i don't you know if
someone
jumps in front of me
it's like i i'm ready to fight them i
can do that because you know i used to
do martial arts but i don't i don't
fear sharks
i'm not swimming with sharks
okay so then let me get it you fear land
sharks
there you go
okay
i should be
fine
thank you heather so i would fear things
in places where such things exist that i
fear but i know never to go there how
about that
okay
so i'll tell you my biggest fear my
biggest fear and i'm sure i'm not alone
in this number one is death i definitely
don't want to die so that's a huge fear
and another and this is probably not a
fear that you have but if anybody
offered me to go to space like go stay
at the international space station i
would say hell no
because the idea of being trapped in a
little tube and away from earth is to me
terrifying so okay i would do it only if
the person who designed the spaceship
had already sent their mother and
brought them back successfully that's
the data that i would use to override
that fear and then i would go
okay so you must have you have a very
strong the prefrontal cortex is strong
in you
guys we got to call it quits there this
has been a fun show i learned a lot um
and
uh this is a great topic maybe we can
revisit it uh in other ways because
there's no end of fear and fear factors
uh in on the scientific frontier
especially in your field of study
heather so
thanks for coming in for this
absolutely thanks for having me all
right chuck always good to have you dude
always a pleasure this has been star
talk we've been talking about the
science of fear and as you know on star
talk we talked about the science of
everything
it happened to be fear this time all
right i'm neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
oh my god i'm sorry i'm watching the
sketch
while you guys were doing that i watched
the sketch it's completely hilarious
no yeah i thought it was like um
you know uh i didn't realize that the
zombies themselves are racist all the
zombies are white
and tea and peeler walking around
and the zombies won't go on because they
think they're afraid of the black people
because they're actually afraid of black
people
and they're zombies and then there's one
scene where the little girl just goes
[Applause]
and the parents go no no no no no
no
the zombie parents are like no no no no
oh my god i'm sorry oh
i'm sorry okay because you've not known
about this you're a good man i can't
believe i
didn't know about that sketch oh my god
that's hilarious it's so funny okay
sorry
oh